we're here today we're the valence
executive producer Anna Donlin Anna
thank you so much for joining us thank
you for having me obviously an exciting
time for you guys but looking back
quickly though I think one of the things
I'm most interested in is what is the
feedback from the community been since
since the beta yeah you know the beta
was overwhelmingly I was just a really
exciting time because like I think we
had a certain expectation of of how many
people might be interested in the game
and we were kind of getting ready for
that and then we'd see if we could like
kind of grow interest over time and then
like interest on day one was was pretty
significant for us so I think beta was
like equal parts testing out a lot of
our theories and making sure that things
were kind of stable and looking ready
but then also we got a very got a crash
course in what does live service feel
like like really fast because we wanted
to let as many people in as we could and
as we did our services started to get to
get fairly strained and then even just
our ability to like kind of keep up with
player feedback I think it's great right
because like that's what live game is
gonna feel like so it definitely got the
team like a little bootcamp and what
that would feel like for sure for the
the response has been really great I
mean the things that we thought weren't
quite ready
we were validated by the community as
not being quite ready so we got a really
good opportunity to prioritize the right
work and the things that we felt were
fairly ready
players were really enjoying so I think
it was it was a it was fantastic for us
honestly so does the new map tie into
the game mode or will all maps be
playing all map will be all maps will be
availabe available on all modes with
with these two modes that we're
launching with that will be the case so
you're adding these on release is is
this kind of gonna be a pattern going
forward are you gonna drip feed content
with a map here and agent there similar
to how overwatch and Rainbow six siege
does it we're not we're so we're not
ready to commit to the exact cadence cuz
I think the main reason why we don't
want to commit to the exact cadence is
we kind of need to see how the game
balances itself out as players are
playing it and we don't want to rush too
much content out there as players are
trying to learn and master what's there
to begin with but we also know that we
need to keep the game fresh and we need
to add new challenges into the gameplay
by adding characters or agents and maps
in at a regular cadence so I think
you can expect from us as if those drops
will feel significant and when they
happen they will feel very deliberate
it's not just gonna be like randomly one
day you wake up and there's a new agents
been introduced or a new Maps been
introduced don't be
it'll be on on a fairly specific cadence
and those moments should feel like
should feel like moments in the game
where the game is changing in some
significant or substantial way and
you've talked a little bit on Twitter
and on your blogs about fixing some of
the issues that have kind of been
plaguing after the most recent update
yes nobody hit rage and FPS and that's
all ironed out for release yes I think I
mean you know I we're never gonna say
things are perfect because that's
impossible and a lot of those issues
were found by us when we kind of went to
scale with closed beta and actually saw
you know more than just our internal
testers playing but I think what we saw
was you know we released we released the
closed beta with really really strong
performance we were really happy with it
out of the gate and then as we were
patching the game things started to
degrade over time in a way that I think
that we noticed but we couldn't we
couldn't see until players were playing
those patches and we started noticing it
and we started quickly like triaging
like how to get back and I think what
we're gonna launch the game with is ver
is is back to what players were
experiencing on that first day if not
slightly better and I think that from
patch to patch well that will be a main
focus for us is making sure that those
things stay consistent it was hard
though because as that as those systems
started to degrade we were also
simultaneously prepping the game for
launch in a number of other ways so
what's good is that all that work is
done now and so now we can just hyper
focus on those on those core things that
we think are integral to the game and
make sure that they don't degrade again
the same way they did over the over the
CB that was really disappointing for us
like even just in the conversations for
launch those things were like we will
not launch this game unless we feel like
we can get those back to our standard
and and I'm really proud of the team
because I feel like they took it they
took it so seriously and they got it
back to that I think players are gonna
be delighted day one but I'm also ready
for them to find new issues for us to to
take care of so you had quite a broad
release day you gave yourself quite a
summer yeah
so why why now what what made you think
that okay this this is when to set a
gang life you know we we've been working
on this game for a long time and we had
this date in mind for the past I'd say
eighteen months we had kind of called
this shot and I maybe not this I think
maybe even the specific date but
definitely the specific kind of like
first half of June was definitely what
we'd set our sights on but you don't
know until the close beta if you're
actually going to be able to do that you
know like we we could have shipped a
closed beta that was so broken and had
so many issues to resolve that it could
have taken us three four or five months
to get ourselves to a place where we
felt this level of confidence to launch
the game which is why we gave ourselves
such a broad you know a broad amount of
time it was like hey like I'm not gonna
say June cuz even though it could be
June 30th like you know players would
want I think I think players would want
especially when they're participating in
a closed beta like that they want to
they want some sort of confidence in one
of the games coming out so we tried to
keep it broad but as we were working
through it you know I saw something in
my team you know I know you didn't
really ask about the work-from-home
thing but I just kind of want to address
it because I saw something in my team
during this work from home period that
showed me their commitment to our player
base like they could have easily come to
me and said Anna let's give ourselves
some time we said summer no one's gonna
be mad if summer means end of August
like let's give ourselves that that
breathing room but they just kind of
doubled down you know it was like no we
said internally June let's do June has
there been any thought about expanding
the player choice when it comes to
letting people that kind of create the
competitive environment they want to
play I've been seeing in the community
there's been talks of wanting pick/ban
phases or knife rounds for attack and
defense as any of that come up in
internal discussion I mean they came up
internal discussion while we were while
we were developing the game for sure I
think what we want to put out there is
something that we feel represents the
core game and then we want to understand
how players are playing it before we put
in extra tools to start you know
preventing certain types of play from
happening or creating that really kind
of bespoke environment for competitive
play but I think those are those are
ideas that are on the table and they're
definitely ideas it works flooring
internally you're the anti cheat system
that you had during the beta I know that
was quite a hot topic for you guys but
you've recently come out and said hey
we've got much more when it comes to
hands Ichi can you go into that a little
bit um yeah so you know anti cheat is
really dependent on cheaters showing up
which is like the hardest part of it
right like the you know we're not going
to create an anti cheat system that is
like a you know it's like a defense wall
that never lets anybody through because
that's what cheaters are great at
they're great at coming up with new
cheats and that's their job and our job
is to sit on the other side of that
detect them and fight them and that
fight is gonna be going on for quite
some time I think some of the things we
were trying to do you know with drivers
and things like that were where we saw
the the easiest access for those
cheaters to get through we were like
well if we just prevent them from
getting that access then we can you know
then we can prevent more and more of
them from getting in the problem is that
became too too invasive on people's
systems and we saw that we've heard that
very quickly and we were like you know
what no we've overstepped for sure and
so we backed off of that but it's meant
we've had to like double down on on you
know hardware ID bans and and things
like that because we really want to get
them out and cheaters are going to their
voice you fight they're going to fight
hard they're not gonna give up so I just
think this is a years-long battle like I
don't think this is about I don't think
it ever really ends and we have an
entire team sitting doing nothing but
this like this is their full-time job so
it's not I don't know if I'm saying
there's gonna be new features that are
gonna come with it but in terms of like
the experience the experience should
continue to get better and better the
more we learn about how they're trying
to attack the game and we'll be at war
on this for for forever I would imagine
we'll be at war on this or forever but
you should be seeing less and less of
them over time if for six if we're
successful
something that I've been requested to
ask what's the new name for he was
always oh you know what doc that Lee was
like I didn't even know who'd like I'm
like who who put that out there I don't
know I don't know the guys you don't
even know the names of in I don't know I
don't know I actually yesterday I was
like we changed it like I didn't even
realize we changed it so I wish I could
answer that question for you I actually
don't know
you'll all find out together I'll
probably find out right after this I
always enjoy a mystery yeah I know that
one's a mystery to me too you know we
liked Valerie because I think like you
know when we start to teasing the lure
right now the game I don't think we've
gone super deep on it yet I mean I know
we haven't gone super deep on it yet
Valerie is representative of something
you know it's so it's a kind of like a
way of being it's like it's like a mark
of like you are of valor and we felt
like it was like if kind of represented
what we think the topmost scale in our
game should be is like you all you have
met you are of valor in that way but
also we understood the trainers just
didn't they just they just didn't
doesn't resonate and it doesn't work and
so we're like okay cool well we'll make
some changes we liked it but you know we
doesn't matter if we like it matters if
you all like it
so do you have any plans for a console
version in the future or is this going
to remain a PC exclusive you know that
one's like I think that that's one of
the more controversial topics out there
like that I've seen and I completely
understand why it's controversial
internally to our dev team as well I
think what we've kind of said is so
we're prototyping that right now like we
are definitely prototyping that right
now but there's a way to play this game
and there's a way to experience this
game that we're not entirely sure
translates completely to console play
and and we really believe that the way
this game is meant to be played isn't it
this like hyper like strong level of
competitive with competitive integrity
and we worry about players feeling like
you know someone they're playing against
has a competitive advantage because of
the system they're playing on and no
matter how much work we do I don't know
if we can ever break that perception so
we need to be really really cautious
about moving forward on on those types
of platforms but I do think there's like
something to crack there that our team
is really excited to crack and so what
we've said is if we feel like we can
deliver this experience on those
platforms we will like we absolutely
will if we feel like we have to
compromise on the experience so much so
that it doesn't even feel like the same
game anymore then we'll just go make
that game and put it on consoles you
know and we'll have that be something
else that we do but we really want
Valerie to stand for a certain type of
gameplay and a certain type of
experience and we want that experience
to be felt across any platform that it's
played on
so it's not a no for sure and I think
you know I've got a bunch of designers
who are very very excited to kind of
prove that this is possible for us but
it definitely wasn't the focus out of
the gate and so it's gonna be if we were
to do it it'll definitely be delayed I
guess a lot of sense well thank you so
much for for hanging out and chatting
with me it's been it's been great to
talk to you you're welcome thank you for
having me I'm sorry I didn't give you
more on Reena but honestly I think we'll
all enjoy learning there together yeah
well it won't be a it'll be a fun time
for all well thank you again for joining
us and anyone out there who wants to
stay tuned for more valerie well stay
tuned to game spot
[Music]